Voxy has a fixation by the reastor.
According to faustice,
voxy would be interested in alastor noting,
but alastor does not differ from the same feeling.
In short,
it's.
Volksy and Lastor do not get along well,
as their views on technology diverge,
as Lastor does not like any technology that came after his death.
decade.
With everything,
Volksy adopts any kind of new technology.
Vox will be and is one of the biggest antagonists in the series.
Vox is a name that can refer to an abbreviation for the word vocals,
but Vox can be a Latin word that has the meaning of voice Vox.
If you built a technological empire in hell.
However,
incredible as it may seem,
all of your company's products start with the letter v,
like a cereal called volt Fruit,
a chocolate bar called vv,
a speaker called Valkyrie.
It has a music app called vogitec Vox.
If it was 1 flat screen TV head,
but it wasn't always like this.
2nd 1 image that was on the dining table
in the radio episode The Killer Star video.
A long time ago,
voxy had an old TV box in its head,
but something happened so that voxy had to change.
Some say that the lastor broke this TV,
so he forgot by the flat screen TV,
however,
voxy can play any video on the TV bar his face.
So let me know here in the comments.
What did you think about these curiosities about our beloved boxing?
Which one did you like the most?
However,
it also leaves the next in the comments.
After all.